dink welcome to the Johno gasps welcome
dick yeah after I know at this tea that
I drink it has like little fortunes on
them oh yeah let's hear what your
fortune is are they like the Oprah
Winfrey ones on yeah yeah they're not
really fortunes they're just like your
thoughts life is a flow of love your
participation is requested oh that
sounds like a booty call on the tea like
an eloquence eloquence nudie booty call
love is requested please provide your
participation love this tea Oh y-yeah
that he wants you bad that he wants to
do girl girl no was it G Oh anyway thank
you guys for joining us today we have
some fun stuff to talk about why don't
you tell them um I want to talk about
conspiracy theories because I really
really like them I enjoy them I've
watched every episode of ancient aliens
ever and I'm obsessed with googling them
and knowing what exists so we each had
to pick like one or two conspiracy
theories and we're going to talk about
whether or not we think that they're
true yeah and yeah that's about it like
I are down the rabbit hole but I don't
think we're ready to go all the way
there this will just be a nice intro
nice little intro he's into Xperia C
theories and I looked up a couple of my
own and I'm really curious to talk about
Jenna's but there were there was some
stuff that really kind of baffled me why
don't we start with more years I say
that we start with something general to
get ourselves warmed up yes yeah that
sounds good yeah this is me warming up
up warm it up let's take that Vienna
that kept putting his finger in mac and
cheese yeah it's
it was just him swirling around mac and
cheese with his pointer finger and the
caption just said does this make you
encounter does sounds like noodles
speaking of which this is totally off
topic but one of the kids at the camp I
used to work at he couldn't hear other
children or other people chewing gum or
eating pasta or else would make him
throw up yeah so he descended in another
table and I think it was for real until
one day on the bus ride home he just
threw up everywhere because a kid next
to him was chewing gum the gum I can
understand pasta chewing gum though I
mean pasta is like grossed I want people
to it gross it can be nasty yeah but
like that kid watch that fine he'd pass
out in his own puke yeah yes sounds like
pasta he probably died anyways I didn't
apparently that's a real thing if
someone tells you that they have that
condition take it seriously yeah they're
not lying yeah don't don't eat pasta in
front of them that's not funny it's not
funny there's no bony all right so I
think that we should warm up let's start
with something classic all right what do
you got Bigfoot mm-hmm okay what are
your thoughts on Bigfoot well I'm
assuming that everyone understands what
Bigfoot is well let's go over just for
those who who may not I guess Bigfoot is
it's a conspiracy theory that there is
existing in the woods somewhere right
that is like what an 8-foot tall
creature who is like mainly human but
he's covered in fur
he's called Bigfoot or Sasquatch right
or a Yeti or a Yeti but basically he
looks like at like a seven or eight foot
tall hairy human and people have claimed
us you know I've spotted him in the
forest but I mean what extent does the
myth go or the urban legend or whatever
you want to call it go like what facts
about him have been put out there like
you know what I mean like is it just so
many okay so why don't we keep it basic
but what are a few of like the popular
facts about Bigfoot besides the fact
that he's big the people have heard him
they hear his noise it well first of all
let's just clarify that the idea of
Bigfoot is
kind of cross-cultural because he's been
spotted in different places yeah look
he's not just you know there's not just
a Bigfoot of like you know North Dakota
people claim to have seen him all over
the world as if it's one or a species as
if it's more than one species okay yeah
that's what a Yeti is not a Yeti the
like thus no one ever got it yeah yeah
yeah
yeah so I think that America is consumed
with the one that apparently lingers
around our woods yeah which is you know
Sasquatch or Bigfoot yeah yes yeah
that's it
yeah I mean I what what are you asking
me like do you think that there's a
Bigfoot I mean here's the thing like the
amount of land to human ratio or the
amount of I should say the amount of
land discovered to the amount of land on
discovered ratio allows for that theory
to be possibility I agree I think that
there's a Bigfoot and you know where
there's lots of Bigfoot I think there's
probably underwater Bigfoot's I think
you're crazy [ __ ] no more the Loch Ness
monster yes but basically I'm not gonna
say yeah I know there's a Bigfoot but
I'm also not going to say no way because
the possibility that it just completely
hasn't even been discovered yet because
of the just the vastness of Earth is is
plausible so yeah I'm gonna go ahead and
say [ __ ] yeah alright [ __ ] yes there's a
Bigfoot and or Yeti and/or sasquatch
yeah they exists because you know what
Julian that many people can't just be
bullshitting that's my opinion no I
agree they're just like these old people
who have nothing to lose
they're just sitting there being like
yeah dude I was [ __ ] playing with my
cows making some money being a farmer
and it [ __ ] why would he make it up
yeah yeah yeah or nothing to gain by
lying yeah rather no for sure so we're
both pretty much on site this is we know
my answers [ __ ] yet but we're on the
same end of the spectrum you're just
further on that end yeah all the way
over so do we need to continue the Big
Buddha or move on no we can move on okay
we're getting warmed up though why don't
you announce it I'm gonna turn down
fires I think that's making the ringing
noise I wanted to learn
so go ahead on that same note though I
think that underwater creatures like
crazy [ __ ] obviously that we don't know
exists because underwater is [ __ ]
like what the we can only go so far down
certain things like abysus there's like
giant cracks like into the [ __ ] earth
that we can't get down I want to know
what the [ __ ] is down there and I think
that Locke the Loch Ness monster is
[ __ ] real yeah the same thing though
same thing why would that many people
just be bullshitting I think people want
to believe after a certain point because
it's so yeah it's magical yeah at this
point yeah that particular it's cool to
believe you legend for sure I think I
just think that well one of the one of
the conspiracies I brought up and we'll
talk about has to do with just a little
bit like the ocean like and how vast it
is mm-hmm like what what I don't even
know what I'm gonna Google what
percentage of the ocean has been you
know what I mean charted unexplored yeah
so okay the ocean covers 71% of the
Earth's surface and contains 97 percent
of the planets water yet more than 95
percent of underwater worlds remains
unexplored mm-hmm that's insane yeah so
yes yes to everything underwater they
all exist they all exist including
julián lead us into your first actual
conspiracy theory that we're gonna talk
about right now okay now that we're
[ __ ] warmed up all right I'm ready
for the conspiracy yeah this [ __ ] is
crazy hit us okay it's basically call I
think it the name of it is called the
hollow Hollow Earth yeah theory and
later we're gonna talk about the hollow
moon theory which was mine which is what
I chose yes love that [ __ ]
yes so I think they're durable written
on this in this fiction also that
centers around this premise but
basically a science fiction journey in
the side of the earth no yeah but that's
very good friend well it's very
different because the just it's just
different I mean yes this is another
girl anyway Hollow Earth
so basically this
conspiracy theory states that the north
and the south pole on earth are
non-existent there is no north or south
pole instead there are gateways to the
inside of planet Earth and if you can
picture it it's like two seas facing
each other so this is what the outer you
know the outer part of our looks like
you know that's the crust that we're on
and then the deepest part of the ocean
and then that's it and then inside
there's in a completely different world
that's existing with an incredibly
advanced like thousands of years further
scientifically and otherwise advanced
species of human who are living a month
sorry
living amongst mammoths dinosaurs aliens
and basically I mean that's kind of just
the general idea of it why this is
interesting is because of the history
behind it so there's this pilot in 1947
for the Air Force and he was taking a
flight somewhere and he was headed
towards the North Pole and it was just
casually flying well he's going he was
going on an exploration flight but he
was truly never end well no they don't
they don't end well give my plate and
explore around why don't you explore in
something else or not explore so he's
flying towards the North Pole this is
1947 so you can imagine one of those old
planes yeah [ __ ] you can't stand up
oh it's the top open also see just got
like God didn't have a it's about that
anyway he's flying over those boats okay
so this is destined to be a great flight
well you don't know the theory of like
the magnetism or anything like just [ __ ]
it let's go fly over it that's the top
of the world
well okay so what a big reason why this
guy Admiral Admiral Byrd was his name
Admiral Richard Byrd was discounted was
because he didn't talk about this right
after it happened and he claims in his
in his journal that which I read with
these entries he claims that he didn't
say that because he was threatened you
know by the US government
when he got back and told everyone the
military got knocked I said yeah so
government man keep going yeah no no no
you're right I'm just trying to gather
with my facts this is just such a crazy
theory anyway so he he like documents in
his journal basically his flight every
like Oh nine fifteen hours in the
distance is what appears to me Mountain
Mountains Oh 955 altitude changes the
twenty nine fifty feet encountering
strong turbulence just normal stuff you
would document on a on a flight then he
goes from okay so he goes from seeing
North Pole type climate like snow
snow-covered mountains glaciers stuff
like that hi he's flying by the way yeah
round 33,000 feet okay um they said like
twenty nine fifty feet anyway so he goes
from he sees these ice and snow and then
he says we were crossing over the small
mountain range is still proceeding
northwards beyond the mountain range is
what appears to be a valley with a small
river of stream running through this
inner portion with a green and a valley
like lots of grass and and he said this
shouldn't be happening as I'm going
north I've only been going north I
should be seeing only snow only ice
stuff like that and then he says you
know because he's only three thousand
feet above ground so he can see things
he's like and then he says I see you
know an elephant or we know no it's a
mammoth it's a mammoth that creature
this thing is huge and there are people
and it this is really crazy but anyway
then he gets to explaining how at a
certain point after seeing this new
climate which is basically like a dream
for him because this is like not real he
loses control of his plane and it feels
like he's just drifting now he's he's
all of his meters were spinning around
he's got no control of the plane so he
starts to just be right completely out
of control but it's not like turbulence
he's just like completely at some other
will yeah so he gets he lands an
inexplicably to tall blond creatures
humans but just tall blonde looking
people approach him and basically take
him to like a meeting in their world
that he's now in the
world of inside earth and then I know
this dragon on but then the basically
what they say to him is you know the
humans your race does not know of our
race they don't we know all that well
they don't know we exist and the reason
why we brought you down here is because
this was like 1947 or ever so he's like
when you guys dropped the bomb on
Hiroshima and Nagasaki we sent a couple
I figured what they call them we sent
our like plane whatever they call their
planes I'm going to look whatever up to
try to intervene and tell you guys or
communicate with you guys that that that
atomic energy is not basically not to be
[ __ ] with like that is going to be the
demise of your species that's going to
be the demise of this planet you guys
cannot mess with atomic bombs and they
didn't listen and they told this guy
like we didn't listen now we're telling
you this poor guy ha he's just trying to
chill and explode now we're telling you
you need to go back and tell everyone
like just like taking the rap for the
entire [ __ ] thing so he goes back
slapping him on the wrist
excuse you tall blond person I didn't do
that and and there's aliens there and
they're they're advanced and their OS he
said he said the car that they took him
from his plane into their room - had no
wheels it was just like a hover car and
this is 1947 and he's writing this a 90
whatever anyway so basically he goes
back he tells his government he's like
you guys this is what the [ __ ] just
happened and they completely silence him
and then his journal entry came out with
a very detailed kind of theory and plot
of what this earth you know than that
and how Hollow Earth could be and
there's plenty of I mean these graphs
that people and and diagrams that people
have come up with and I mean it's very
very extensive but basically that's it
okay so let's break that down for one
second yeah yeah I will go ahead and be
the first one to say that I am all on
board for Hollow Earth theory now before
we even get into any of this yeah I will
have you guys
I think I already said this I think I've
said this a million times I'm obsessed
with ancient alien theory which is to
simply put the idea that aliens have
been around forever and ever much much
longer than we have we are the planet of
the children and that everything that
has happened in human civilization
aliens have had a hand in and it crosses
through to religion like that gods
aren't actually gods they're just like
aliens that help us and tell us how to
live our lives and lo'laan
oh great job pyramids just kidding good
serious scientific help if you want to
go down a rabbit hole
watch ancient aliens on anything what
it's on A&E yeah I think it's not going
on China you can find it probably on
Netflix or Hulu or some [ __ ] like that
it's worth looking into some of them
yeah it's a stretch but I just love the
idea yeah and that's how I feel about
all conspiracy theories but I am
particularly invested in ancient alien
theory not as in like I'm completely
sold this is how the world works yeah
but I thoroughly enjoy it and I love
entertaining the idea and I really do
like I love some of the things that they
point out they do a good job they do a
good job of their of making up sense
because I feel like they really focus on
specific incidences they break it down
they break it down underwater focus on
guys so that's why getting back to what
you just pointed out is like one
teeny-tiny theory that they would point
out in an episode of ancient aliens yeah
that would be compelling judo enemies
yeah yeah so I'm all bought into Hollow
Earth all all the way I mean the the
rationale of your brain says okay not
[ __ ] now like of course science no it
does it well no one says yes yeah what
I'm saying is like your initial thoughts
as a human who lives in the 21st century
and knows what science has been
discovered and all that stuff says okay
of course it can't be Hollow
everything that science has taught us
says it can't be Hollow says it can't be
Hollow to the point where there's an
entire world and then a son in the
middle of the world like an atmosphere
yeah
why are we on the outside can we go on
the inside what you do have to you do
have to wonder a little bit you don't
have to like suspend like logic for a
second and think about why it's even the
thing why people even take the time to
come up with this stuff or think about
it or spread the rate well that's why I
love conspiracy theories so much because
you can't get to that without expanding
your mind to do enemy yeah like oh sorry
thank you good like I I just want to
know what other people think yeah like
what other people are just sitting
around thinking about things what do
they [ __ ] hypothesize yeah so
somebody found this guy's journal or
whatever and you know typed it up on the
Internet
yep this happened a long time ago I'm
assuming people have found it and read
it
8:47 right no no no that but I'm saying
that people started spreading the word
around that it exists yeah yeah and then
the what you're saying about the graphs
and the pictures and the the writing
supporting it I know I see that like
that's what I like that people get
consumed by it and then give you all the
reasons that it could possibly be true
yeah cuz it runs away it snowballs and
then it turns into something that you
can't ignore if you're looking at
something this is [ __ ] awesome so
we're looking at a picture right now
just the top of the earth with it it's
basically like a sinkhole in the top of
here that's like the size of you know
[ __ ] Russia yeah that's how big it is
good picture guys crazy um so what do
you think of this I mean you just you
just think yes it's completely possible
there's an advanced species living
amongst aliens man it's dinosaurs inside
of our earth with a new Sun well here's
the problem is that Earth is widely
accepted to be made of a dense solid
core widget when we talk about Hollow
Earth or theory it's the same sort of
thing like you have a seismic activity
like there's earthquakes and [ __ ] that
aren't really like don't align with
having a hollow core yeah but what well
do you know the deepest we've explored
inside the earth in real life not no
idea not as
keep talking about everything science
would point to the idea that earth has a
solid core and I you know believe that
it's not that I don't believe science
it's just that I like conspiracy
theories more it's more exciting it's
more fun yeah why not why not so I'm
looking at the Kola super-deep borehole
which is apparently the deepest anyone
has ever dug into earth they reached
12,000 262 meters which is basically
40,000 feet in 1989 which is still the
deepest artificial point so now if we're
looking at this graphic 40,000 feet it
doesn't get in get you didn't get you
source that doesn't even get you close
to where they're seeing our outer earth
hands right they say it ends 800 miles
have we ever broken through the crust of
the earth well if it's deeper than
40,000 then know which mean parts of the
crust have to be because this this Kola
super-deep hole is saying it drilled was
stopped I mean yeah the drill string was
twisted off and left in the hole yeah
cuz they're like [ __ ] man we're going
nowhere yeah we go in nuclear no way
anyway the point is is that this theory
has not technically been disproven right
I mean yeah like we well okay it hasn't
it hasn't because we know how solid
objects act we know how solid planets
act do we though we do ask the people
[ __ ] NASA yeah we don't know how how
planets in the Hollow Earth world would
act like what if what if old on no what
if like this the geography of the Hollow
Earth is like a completely foreign
science to us and we have no idea if
that could be real because we don't know
anything about it like there's nothing
to study to compare that to oh yeah I
see where you're going and I think what
I have can help you articulate that but
I think the general laws of gravity
we're assuming apply to solid objects
the earth responds like a solid object
okay Jeremy yeah for sure
no I'm playing I'm playing a little bit
doesn't double them no I know you are
yeah because I'm I love hollow [ __ ]
moon theory like there's no tomorrow and
every time I look at the moon and get
obsessed with it so I buy into Hollow
Earth theory I see what you're saying
okay so okay time out though what do you
think happens in the middle of the earth
who do you think resides in there
besides mammoths tall blonde very smart
thousands of years advanced genius
people flying on their hoverboards but
they're not people well they are a
people they're up there are people
they're not they're not our race like
Marvel's they are a different race they
are not like the human race they are an
altered advanced version of us which in
turn makes them different so that's I
obviously we're the aliens a devil's
advocate over here I think this could be
completely true it's just so [ __ ]
insane to think about I mean I love
thinking about this stuff because it
really just like suspends my mind like I
never thought about this stuff so now
that I can think about it it's like you
never think about this I've never
thought about that if the earth was
Hollow and there was a come on
you have you thought about what are you
talking about you ever watched ancient
aliens all right you talk about you know
how much ancient aliens I've watched ah
everyone falls asleep when they want to
watch ancient aliens with me I'm the
only one it's like glued to it like
[ __ ] losing my mind
it was everyone else to sleep it doesn't
want me to sleep I'm just saying means
anyway it's cool the thing about this so
I'd like to think that it could be true
why don't we segue right into the hollow
moon theory what is that okay so
basically the hollow moon theory is that
the moon is hollow etc on your moon
because the the one that I'm going to
talk about because there are theories
that it's just [ __ ] Hollow yeah but
the one I'm going to talking about is
that it's actually a spaceship okay and
is that the hollow moon there yeah okay
there's a [ __ ] spaceship all right
and are you ready it up these are these
are the five ideas as to how the moon
came to exist one is by capture so that
like the earth is heavier and denser and
it as it was traveling through space it
captured the moon and then it got into
Earth's orbit okay but people don't
agree with that because they have
essentially identical oxen oxygen
isotope ratios which is [ __ ] okay I
shouldn't say that word sorry for
offending everyone okay and and a close
encounter with earth typically results
in either collision or altered
trajectories which the moon has almost a
perfect circle orbit of Earth yeah
not elliptical okay slightly elliptical
obviously or else it doesn't [ __ ]
work but that's banana cracker the other
idea there's five of these okay of how
just how the moon was formed okay which
all are sort of wonky yeah was that it
sort of flew out of the Pacific Ocean
because of the gravity cific oceans big
enough right okay let me just read this
it's a desert this theory states this
during a time when the earth was forming
and was still molten the spinning of the
planet projected out material which
became our Moon today the Pacific Ocean
was supposedly the area where the moon
came from however this was debunked
considering the immaturity of the ocean
floor crust and knowing that the moon
formed much longer ago so for example
we've studied the rocks on the moon
they're older than the ones on the earth
yes so almost all of these that claim
that it was part of the earth before
can't possibly be true because okay
because science has said what's on the
moon is older than what's on earth right
um
the other theory is that they formed
together at the same time bounine earth
yes okay but the problem is that does
not explain the angular momentum of the
Earth Moon system or why the moon has a
relatively small iron core compared to
the earth 25% of its radius compared to
50% of the earth driving a more radical
alternative hypothesis published in 2010
proposes the moon may have been formed
from the explosion of a Geo actor
whatever the dick that is geo reactor
actor geo reactor you right you right
I'm an idiot
located along the core-mantle boundary
lalalalala don't know what that means
but people don't accept it the giant
impact theory was the most widely
accepted for a while which was the idea
that some other planet or thing within
our solar system crashed into the moon
and then made what is the moon today but
people don't agree with that either
because the material on the [ __ ] moon
isn't really found anywhere else in our
solar system so [ __ ] suck dick
the moon's older than the earth the
rocks the chemical composition of the
dust upon which the rocks at differently
remarkably from the rocks themselves the
dust underneath the rocks are different
yeah which means that the rocks were
brought from somewhere else
there's heavier elements on the surface
of the Moon then underneath the surface
of the Moon which is [ __ ] backwards
yes cadet but can't that be attributed
to the lack of gravity mmm I don't know
the answer to that but sorry timeout
just let me [ __ ] up gods rise [ __ ]
there's water vapor lunar instruments
placed by astronauts recorded a water
vapor cloud of water passing across the
surface of the Moon the cloud lasted 14
hours and covered an area about 100
square miles tell me that that [ __ ]
anyways the most compelling evidence has
yet to come so just [ __ ] hold your
dick on hold and rotate the rocks are
[ __ ] magnetic so Julian okay um hey
I'm Luke no you were like you're ridges
over there hey I'm go the rocks are
magnetic the most compelling to me I am
just [ __ ] cut to the chase alright
the most compelling to me is that the
craters yeah they're huge some of them
but the depth of them don't make any
sense and the bottoms of a lot of them
are flat or they're even convex but you
wouldn't align with something hitting it
right yeah so the idea is that it has
like a solid inner hull which is
basically a [ __ ] spaceship and then
they covered it with rocks from another
place so like that we don't know they're
magnetized so they [ __ ] stick to this
because the small ones if it gets hit
with
small craters it has you know a regular
reaction but the big ones you like
assuming the the radius of this [ __ ]
comet whatever the [ __ ] is hit it it
should be a lot [ __ ] deeper they're
huge
no but instead it went bang and a
discussion they're [ __ ] shallow
there's hundreds of moon quakes up there
like mostly science that's what they
have argued is like noted they have
seismic activity to have earthquakes so
you think that were attributed to the
spaceship moving yeah well yeah that's
good yeah and the other idea is the the
moment of inertia I think is what
they're talking about the when something
comes into the area that it could be
pulled into their gravitational pull how
fast and how hard that is to no means no
it aligns with you know a little bit
less than Earth so that it seems like it
would be a solid dense core I guess I've
had a hollow-core in the moment of
inertia or whatever would be a lot less
yeah yeah anyways um this one's my
favorite
I got [ __ ] I'm finding it moon echoes
okay you ready for this I'm ready
Oh on November 20th 1969 the Apollo 12
crew they whatever they loved a lot too
much fancy language basically they
landed on the moon but they crashed into
it sort of and it created an artificial
moon quake with the startling
characteristics the moon reverberating
like a bell for more than an hour
because the inside is metal into space
yeah what do you think happens when you
crash something giant into something
hollow it sounds like a [ __ ] Bell if
the moon is what we think it is what do
you think the reaction would have been
what does that mean like if something
crashed into it like a spaceship and
it's the moon it's a solid moon ring
like a bell duh I just told you that no
but that supports the theory that it's a
spaceship right what I'm saying is if
this moon just crashing burn and it
won't like it things move wouldn't shake
right because things crash in Earth's
orbit time yeah
okay that serves a snow and the earth
doesn't rain the ringing thing is pretty
hot that argument
that's pretty [ __ ] crazy okay anyways
keep going our moon is the only moon in
the solar system have stationary near
perfect circular orbit although it's so
elliptical lalalala it's just not
possible if you watch ancient aliens in
the episode they talk about this it's
just like the the perfection of it the
size the orbit the the fact that it
perfectly aligns with the Sun to make a
complete eclipse it's just bananas it's
like not [ __ ] possum okay so who's
operating the spaceship do you think
well the idea is that there's a
reptilian race of aliens that use it
they went there because there's a hold
on I'm gonna jump the gun here I'm
asking questions I'm going to ask
questions
okay so there's ancient people whatever
the mining into their names but they
have a [ __ ] yeah now I see it looks
like panicky to try and read something
and talk about at the same time well
take your time I'm listening
Zulu Shama and Cradle mu to us said that
Zulu legends believe the moon to be a
hollow home of the python or cheetah Rui
but basically there are these people in
Bolivia and they have their writings and
sculptures about when the moon's first
started being in the sky and then it
caused all these cataclysmic events and
[ __ ] okay but that the moon wasn't
always in the sky and then all of a
sudden it was so as if it was a
spaceship it just approached and then
arrived well nobody like flew the moon
over its the according to legend they
rolled it from the Sun to where it is
oh they rolled it from the Sun and
according to these people also women did
not men straight before the moon arrived
like a lot of things did not happen
there were no red tidal waves anything
right and then after the moon arrived
[ __ ] got [ __ ] real well okay I mean I
you stole more to go though right no
that's that's what
parts but there's a lot of stuff on it I
love that [ __ ] I want to watch will you
show me that episode I want to watch
that episode yes okay I want to watch it
it's so amazing
they'll also the one about underwater
like places is amazing cuz these things
I've never even seen or heard about on
their ears like what the [ __ ] how come
we're not talking about this yeah
friends know yeah I'll give it to you
some of those episodes really just kind
of like hit you in the face with like
the amount of like coincidences and
you're just like what well yeah some of
it you're just like all right dude
alright Georgio aliens this is your way
this is such a stretch it's not even
funny
yeah but then some of it is really
compelling ya know for sure for sure I
want to watch that episode yeah it's
great
ancient aliens alright so what are you 2
cents hollow hollow moon theory yes or
no yeah you're nay what do you got well
to be fair I don't want to say something
and then go research it later which I do
plan on doing and then have myself
kicked myself because I'm like oh wow I
should have thought about this so I'm
not going to give you a full answer but
I do think that if I go look this stuff
up and I watch that episode with you and
there's any sort of solid I don't know
solid reasoning or any any way to
believe that that whole ringing thing is
true cuz that's pretty crazy me that's
what really I'll take that I will take
anyone excited enough about the hollow
moon theory to be a win well I want to
see basically I want to look at the
validity of that ringing story okay like
I want to I want to see what so do you
know when that was it's a 19 something
76 okay so it's not ancient okay so yeah
I mean like if that if that story has
any sort of any sort of validity to it
I'd be interested in looking at that
more but no I mean right now I think the
moons the moon man I've been looking at
that moon different ever since ancient
aliens [ __ ] air made mom different
every there came a time when I was
watching an alien yeah this is like I'm
obsessed with it I don't care like every
single episode I would just be googling
things furiously after the episode was
over like I get that excited about
everything that they present I know you
I know I guess like I'd go down you're
beginning yeah no for sure I love it
it's crazy to think about yeah it's just
like when I was reading that whole
hollower thing it's like I want to learn
more about that there's like a couple
books on it
I'm gonna read those books all right
what's your next theory because I'm I'm
at total I'm as much as reasonably able
to be bought into hollow moon theory as
possible as a functioning adult that's
not an [ __ ] all right I have one uh
it's called North Korean utopia yes
basically it's that North Korea is
really the only country on Earth to have
achieved a perfect utopia and everything
we hear about North Korea is propaganda
let's make I miss that show all right
Pete we were like one of six people that
watch that show got canceled in Rome was
about one of the other and Bret was by
the other so we were four of six people
but so yeah although all the stuff we
hear about North Korea about how you
know it's what a military state and
people get whatever all the stuff we
hear is just propaganda to make them
safe from us knowing that they have
achieved utopia and the US government
isn't on it they know about it but they
are protecting North Korea by feeding us
what they feed us so basically that's it
mmm you're odd has been in North Korea
my yes she has she's been to North Korea
that is crazy she worked for the Library
of Congress for a lot of years she's
been too you know something insane over
a hundred countries like she's been to
places that you can't [ __ ] go to yeah
one of which and recently I'd like
within the last five years has been to
North Korea and I haven't had a chance
to sit down and talk with her because
the last time I saw her was my brother's
wedding yes wasn't really an appropriate
time to pick her brain about her visit
to North Korea um but apparently you
know she wasn't really allowed to take
pictures and like do stuff like that
because they do not want like you you go
there and I even know how she went but
it's not like she can come home and be
like hey friends and family here's all
the wonderful things that in North Korea
like they don't they don't want people
to know you know which gives validity to
this theory it's a secret for all we
know there could be beaches and Gatorade
drinking fountain well it also gives
validity that my Aunt Mary is a like
wonderful majestic like I hope to be her
when I grow up she was like one of the
best people on the planet and she got
invited to this secret utopia she went
to the real utopia I mean it's a [ __ ]
up theory in theory it is pretty [ __ ]
up I don't believe this I don't believe
it either but it's funny to think about
though it's a little bit ridiculous ya
know it's I mean what's the consensus
I'm saying no I say no completely here's
one thing though and this this is just
purely my thoughts there's nothing
behind this but it's just that like if
you've traveled to a different country
you get a quick understanding how
different America is from the world and
having been lucky enough to go outside
the country multiple times to places
that are not like America I sit here and
think about that I'm like of course
North Korea is what it is
it's not a utopia but if you were just
someone who had never left America if
you were American I'm speaking to you
and you hear this theory you think oh
maybe that's maybe that's real but you
know what I'm saying like you don't
really mmm cuz you're an idiot well it's
not that you're an idiot you're just no
dude it's like shrouded in secrecy major
high just and good over there although
what an optimistic conspiracy theory
right that's such a nice that person is
definitely thinking glass half-full give
them that one the person who can know
what is just like shitty like no country
that's causing all sorts of it's a
really high kid mean whatever that kid
is and guy ten guy ten guy that's his
name - yes yeah you say that like what
if North Korea is actually just a utopia
what is that
their country that's causing all sorts
of bad thing
is a military state is actually just
like beaches yeah [ __ ] oh my god I
just I only said that because like you
once you see a third-world country not a
third-world country just a country
that's very different than America it
becomes real in your mind like the
things you hear about North Korea it can
be it can it's possible hmm I'm glad
that you brought that conspiracy theory
in though because I like I like the ones
that are just like wait a [ __ ] second
what wait a [ __ ] second yeah for sure
what was your other one IRA moving on
from that let's move on for now do you
have another one go to your next one
things better like I like the one I like
the one that uh Hitler never actually
died and he left in his submarine went
in Arctica and there were a secret race
of people there that accepted him and
decided he was like cool and so he just
lived he's frozen
it's called frozen Nazis oh my god oh my
god
okay uh no comment oh I know what I
wanted to say just to go back to yours
for one second yeah why would it be a
problem for the rest of the world to
know that North Korea was a utopia cuz
then everyone would go to North Korea
and they'd have to kill everyone okay
but utopia isn't for everyone we know
that this is toughy okay alright doctor
okay I want it all right I love the ones
that that conspire that people died and
then people didn't die and then like
there was one that's him Elvis like
Tupac they're everywhere yeah I was
reading of course read it and someone
was like there's one that Eminem died
like 15 years ago and there's been a
clone pretending to be him since and
someone was like well there's related to
this have you seen him stand up have you
seen the real Slim Shady stand up and
then they linked like a bunch of
pictures of him sitting down it has like
couldn't she will but know the ones of
people who there's there's one I read
that so when Michael Jordan was playing
baseball
all like he took his hiatus whatever to
play baseball and he got those trouble
what's David Stern the theory is that
the punishment wasn't for that it was
for his NBA gambling addiction like he
had gambled on NBA games and that way he
could keep Michaels image safe while
also punishing it which I don't doubt
it's like the show [ __ ] playmakers
which I can't get anywhere else I
haven't really tried
you should try North Korea I heard that
they have like a full library of
anything you ever want to watch oh my
god seriously though like it's don't
look up what kind of person Michael
Jordan is it's so disappointing it is
he's such a bad guy yeah but yeah anyway
sorry that I think I think the like that
and there was another one not the frozen
Nazis but it was basically not it was
like a combat combination to that my
other one it was that Nazis and Hitler
we're not eliminated or whatever there
they are living in the center of the
earth yeah they just pieced out when to
the middle yeah they're just in the
middle what we´d okay if let's run with
it okay let's remove it when are they
coming back if ever mm and Hitler I
don't know I don't know I feel like they
they're just chilling in there to do
what what's there nothing why do they go
there how do they get there okay but if
you go to the center of the earth do you
also simultaneously gain immortality no
well then they're not still there well
yeah they are yeah yeah they [ __ ] are
no what if they went down there with
like time whimpers oh yeah
what if yes I was gonna say they
reproduce but that's a better thing or
it's a different dimension it's the end
to mention mm-hmm that's what it is it's
the enth dimension you can Akito roll
into the shower and then just end up
there mm-hmm
what's it called I can oh my browser
quick but it's called
the real what we're making up for the
Nazis down there well I don't know I I
was asking what it was called okay so
let me find it hold on say um is it
called utopia this is you tell it's not
call me yeah let's say Caban is it's
actually it's actually really not called
Toby yeah
I hope it has some really awesome name
where else gonna be no it does there is
a Garza a Garza Agartha okay yeah are
Hollow Earth comm Garza you know what I
wish would come back though what Pangaea
ooh you want us just to like merge
together yeah all land just merge back
together in a mob of like just a land
yeah Garza Agharta
the guard time has it the land of
advanced races hmm
races plural Oh Gabe city of shamballa
do you think that there's like turmoil
oh no they're thriving that's why
they're trying to send messages to
Admiral Admiral Byrd like you guys stop
fighting you're gonna hurt yourself and
[ __ ] your race up and you'd think that
they'd bring more people down there to
spread the message more oh you don't get
on Twitter or something Carta do they
have Twitter like built into their
eyeballs like they are so advanced yeah
I'm looking at this graph right now
anything like that they just speak with
their brains Oh
so [ __ ] crazy it's basically showing
that Mount Everest interests Everest
Everest okay enough making fun of me for
my pronunciation of Mount Everest eight
thousand eight hundred eighty two meters
tall which is why they have it like like
ten kilometers I don't know what
basically that's just a ridiculous
fraction of how deep the crest goes like
just showing us how little we and then
here it is the deepest part of the ocean
which is another like basically Mount
Everest you know what I mean and then
then it's basically a Garda mmm I want
to go to a garden well all you got to do
is jump in a plane and go north [ __ ] man
and then when you lose control of your
plane that's when you
hmm or you're dead sounds great sounds
not worth it is that were Amelia too
soon Oh too soon let's not talk about
too soon when shall we make jokes about
her let's talk about planes it makes me
very anxious don't don't get you at
hands at you yeah my hands will get much
bombs are itchy
that's a rome says when she gets like
anxious and nervous my hands are itchy
when I played the creepy song for her
her hands got itchy
what was your other one about the guy it
was a time traveler but it was basically
this guy I don't know I didn't do the
problem is I didn't like read too much
into it because I was busy reading about
Encarta but his name is John tied or or
tit or no that's tied or and he
basically claimed to be from 2036
awesome invented a time machine
awesome went to 2001 Joey gone ah she
got on a bunch of internet forums
claimed this posted pictures of his time
machine and pictures of the operation
manual answered every single question
that people had asked them and then
disappeared forever gone basically back
to 2036 is what people theory so no one
knows where he is no no no serious
worries but I'm sure he's just not like
it is farmhouse he predicted apparently
he predicted you tell us about his
predictions well I don't know too much
about his predictions but I know that he
predicted look at this site this is a
claim is on the coast to coast am that
guy's all over ancient aliens alright
then I'm down with this yeah but
basically AI he predicted some sort of
mad cow breakout and it happened very
close to how he predicted it mm so he
had a couple of these predictions that
were that like were made valid because
of how they actually kind of turned out
to be true and okay so here let me read
some of the question and answers yeah I
want to know
let's see can you explain what the
purpose of time travel is on your world
line in 2036 he says a great deal of
effort is going into repairing our
environment I was sent to 1975 to get a
computer system and take it back to 2036
time travel is not a secret in 2036 and
I expect it will become more common like
these are the answers he is giving this
guy what how did they pick this guy - we
got to find the core 36 did he just
build his own time machine we gotta fix
I gotta find that question we gotta ask
cancer or AIDS miniatures yet cured yet
sorry AIDS no cancer some progress Wow
that's hopeful what is the entertainment
industry in like 2036 again
entertainment is less centralized there
are movies and TV but everything is
distributed over the net and more people
produce their own shows that sounds like
right now how far all right I like that
question who won the Superbowl in 2001 I
do not answer questions like this
although I don't really know the
motivation for the question I can guess
if a Time Trial will have knowledge of
your future and you only ask one
question
would this be it he's basically saying
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you yeah it's GPS used in
2036 oh yes in fact I have them with me
it works here I'm not sure why that
surprises me I don't know this guy seems
like a troll well here's the thing he
then predicted sorry I don't I got lost
there
he then predicted a second Civil War and
World War three right which didn't which
didn't happen we putting attributed a
you predict them to happen obviously
before 2036 because that's the year that
he's saying I think he predicted it to
happen in like five years after like two
doesn't want um someone asked him what
his favorite food is but he was saying
that he said that was like another 10
percent deviation yeah and if that's a
two percent deviation yeah
what's a five or seven percent deviation
ten percent deviation God so how did we
arrive at two percent
John John Titor um keep going I want to
hear March I look a better question no
just read them all right well there's a
long answer
let's see what happens - okay okay here
we go what do they look for when
choosing someone for mission depending
on the mission time travelers are
usually chosen for a particular mission
based on their ability to gain the
cooperation of someone related to the
goal on the target world line interests
in my case my grandfather was directly
involved with the building and
programming of the 5100 which is
apparently his time machine okay that's
a good answer how do you know our world
line and yours will follow the same path
this world line in my own are almost
exactly alike so I guess world lines are
like the linear like time tables and
he's crazy yeah that hurts my brains
that is a lot woman where's the new US
Capitol the new US Capitol is in a lotta
bratok no he did not say that I do
is it possible to send a message through
time unless the person in that sorry
unless the information physically
travels with a person none that I'm
aware of what like I just want to know
what happened to him how does he have a
name like how did he get around without
I believe it was all on internet forums
you can look further I might be wrong
but that's it seems like troll fuel whoa
yeah well that makes canceled eight
11:04 that's not right that happened nah
dude uh sorry about that little break
our camera apparently didn't want to
record a ring-card be full do anyway do
you have any more you want talk where
you want to end it there
no those really I really just want to
talk about full moon theory I'm removing
Hollow Earth that's a good start I feel
like we could all get deviated well I
want to watch more each an alien sin
that way I'll have a better okay if you
want to go to sleep
everyone I know that I've watched it
with him like you gotta watch this they
just fall asleep all right well I want
to go to sleep soundless he's kidding
some of them give me nightmares good
I'll fuel your nightmares
number one on iTunes thank you guys for
watching I hope you enjoyed our
conspiracy theory discussion yeah and if
you guys hate this then just like [ __ ]
off guys and we'll never do it again but
if you like this I'm [ __ ] Auggie to
sit here and talk about this for days
yeah let us know and also if you have
interesting consider these conspiracy
theories you want to talk about comment
and tell us and also tell us if you
think we're right or wrong because we're
probably wrong so we will be back next
Monday with another podcast we didn't
tell you we were working on our new
podcast room so you might see us in a
different room next week or might be the
week after but regardless we are gonna
have a better setup and we're getting a
better camera eventually so it's gonna
look better for you guys it's gonna
sound the same for you guys are you
driving your mom you better give it up
you better drive a little slower yeah
food rush let's pump the braces you're
gonna merge in front of someone and have
them get angry alright thank you guys
for watching
show it right here